[Music]
after 9/11 everyone was scared scared it
might happen again it was my second day
of grad school next day I changed all my
classes to national security
morning gang morning Center have you
seen the story today in the New York
Times evidently the CIA destroyed tapes
of interrogations of al-qaeda detainees
I want to find out what was on the tapes
why they were destroyed no paper papers
with getting people in trouble
at our place at our place papers so we
keep track of laws last night I found
this he's detaining number 24 you guys
see this no no watch the video they
waterboarded him a hundred and eighty
three times everything they got from him
was either a lie or something they
already had if it works why do you need
to do it 183 times maybe when the report
comes out people will finally see that
Ivy mentally disagree with the narrative
here the United States does not torture
dan you need to be careful here they
can't destroy the document so they can
go after the next best thing
yeah they claim they save lives but what
they really did was make it impossible
to prosecute a mass murderer because if
what we did to him ever came out in a
court of law
the case is over the guy planned 9/11 we
will not allow this to be covered
antennas to gain Intel save American
long histories written by the victors
you need to change our promise that even
epic nothing could be further from the
democracy is messy if The Times had your
report we would print it tomorrow know
if it's gonna come out it's gonna come
out the right way
[Music]